للوهله الاولى تشعر انك في قلبي معركه لا
تبقي ولا تذر برا وجوا
غير ان الصوره من قريب في اقليم النيل
الازرق هي لختام مهرجان الرمايه السابع
والخمسين للجيش السوداني بمشاركه مختلف
الوحدات العسكريه وبحضور قائد عام الجيش
السوداني الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان
الذي لم ينفك يرسل رسائل عسكريه وسياسيه
اللهم صلح قوات محترفه ما عندها علاقه
بالتنظيمات السياسيه ما فيها اخوان ولا
فيها يساريين ولا في ايه يمنيين قوات
مسلحه سودانيه حق السودان هي صمام امان
هذا السودان عشان كذا بنقول نحن والله
ماشيين في التوافق الحصل نحن متوقع انه ما
تم توقيعه من اتفاق اطاري يخرج هذه البلاد
من وحدته ويوحد شملنا ويوحينا عشان نبني
هذا البلد
مهرجان الرمايه في نسخته السابعه والخمسين
حمل رسائل للعسكريين وللمدنيين هنا في
اقليم النيل الازرق الذي يعيش على وضعه
والتراث بين مجموعات قبليه